breaking news breaking news breaking
news the s p 500 just hit another
all-time high congratulations world
record smp number that's three days of
the week let's go baby 60 of the week we
were hitting all-time highs in the s p
500 just on an absolute rocket ship send
it the s p 500 has no ability to go down
they have outlawed bear markets they
have absolutely banned any sort of bear
market and every time that we get
anywhere near a market correction they
just step in and they start talking
about creating money spending money
manipulating interest rates the s p 500
is on a straight
rocket ship to the moon or as the island
boys would say is to the sun now you
have to remember that the s p 500 the
growth in the s p 500 is all denominated
in dollars and so if it is denominated
in dollars you have to think about the
idea of is it actual true growth or is
it because the dollar is being devalued
we've got a tweet here that somebody
sent me that's it adjusted for the money
supply uh or i'm sorry just for money
supply expansion the s p has not hit an
all-time high since 2000. so if you take
away all of the manipulation around the
money supply expansion the s p has not
hit an all-time high but ultimately the
money supply expansion doesn't
necessarily matter because all people
care about is what is the dollar figure
and as long as i'm holding an asset and
the money supply is absolutely being
decimated because it keeps expanding and
the value of the dollar is falling then
it is going to go up in dollar terms and
so when you have an s p 500 that hits
all-time high after all-time high after
all-time high three times this week it's
literally done it like 50 plus times
this year we are getting close to almost
100 all-time highs i don't think we're
going to get there this year but almost
100 times this year we may get an
all-time high which would be absolutely
bonkers and so what you have to remember
is that yes it is going up in dollar
terms but when you start to control for
money supply expansion we are not at an
all-time high and john i think you and i
have talked about this a bunch of times
it just keeps going up and up and up
it's not going to stop we're always
going to get new all-time highs because
the currency is being devalued so
quickly right
yeah i agree um look as the currency
gets devalued obviously assets that are
denominated in the currency is getting
devalued are obviously appreciating
value right technically in the in the
terms they're going to go up and up the
term of the dollar and we've talked
about how if you denominate things in
bitcoin it actually um has gone down in
value a bunch right uh i the smp is a
beast of its own tesla honestly went on
a tear this week so wrapping up that i
mean what we're gonna see ultimately if
the market corrects um
it can't correct like it's not gonna
correct 50 again like we saw last year
during the pandemic or anything like
that so i think it'll be a minor
correction if it does the s p 500 has
been exploding it's been accelerating
and appreciating against the dollar but
the s p 500 has absolutely been
decimated compared to bitcoin the s p
500 has been crashing against bitcoin
which is really interesting because it
ultimately shows what is the asset what
is the currency that you were going to
denominate the s p in if it's dollars
you'll make a ton of money if it's
bitcoin you're losing a ton of money by
holding the s p joe what do you think
while you lay back there like you're
strolling the streets of south la
about the smp
about the all-time high and also about
uh bitcoin actually having it what
you're saying it's a video game yeah you
call it yeah i already tweeted it i said
the s p 500 had an all-time high nothing
is real we live in a video and then what
did you say at the beginning of the
pandemic all you had to do was uh get lo
buy assets get long shut up and they're
going to literally no they're starting
to like chilling in there oh get long
and uh shut up and chill yeah shut up
shut up and chill if you wanna shut up
and chill if you did not buy assets in
march of 2020 and chill
then you didn't do anything compared to
what those people did because all you
had to do was literally take your
currency your cash
put into some assets
lay back like joe i'm chilling exactly
what i'm doing
i like doing this
they're going to send those asset prices
to the moon everything's up literally
everything is up over the last 12 months
the s p 500 is up 40
the s p 500 is up 40
in the last 12 months in the last five
years it's only up 116
so quite literally in the last 12 months
has been one of the best times in the
stock market in recent memory 40
increase in a 12-month period if you put
a hundred dollars in you got 140 bucks
now
that's how the game's played bitcoin up
360 percent so it's better to have
bitcoin but even if you just had the s p
500 they literally pumped your bags to
the